right the relationship between the
variables using K as the constant of
variation okay so it says we're going to
do this two ways okay so firstly that
let's have a look at one a and there are
two variables what are they no no no
have a look and ah so I'm just gonna
write a and armed these guys are okay
these guys are not proportional to each
other because look again at the question
it's actually not our read it again it's
the square of the radius square those so
what I have to write is R squared okay
so I can say a is proportional to R
square but we actually know we have a
formula for the area of a circle right
what's the formula what is it actually
equal to it's PI R squared and pi is
that constant PI's are number 3.1415 etc
and it never changes yeah unlike these
guys the whole point is you have big
circles and small circles you can change
the radius to do whatever you want pi
never changes so this is the formula for
the area so unless you eat it of course
but then asked us look at the question
it says use K as the constant of
variation okay so the particular K we we
actually know this formula but this is a
more general way to say it okay
K for now in this particular context is
PI but if I didn't know what that was
but once a lot of time people didn't
have a label for that so they're like I
don't know it's some constant don't know
what it is okay
please know it might be worth writing
down with some other color if you've got
one this is the constant of variation
so in a way it controls how fast or slow
the variation is happening not to be
confused with new color these guys are
and a and they are actually variables so
the phrase constant of variation is kind
of a it sounds like an oxymoron it's
like it's constant but it's about change
but the number itself doesn't change
it's these guys that change a dog okay
can you tell me how to do B we can do it
just like this hmm
okay so firstly I'm gonna start with is
B I'm gonna write my proportionality
symbol like so what's it proportional to
yeah the cube of the radius okay now
again on the reference sheet because we
do spherical geometry we actually know
what the volume is equal to right does
anyone remember I don't know don't
consult it cuz I do but I'm just asking
if you guys remember do you remember it
so it's 4/3 PI R cubed okay
so just like pi is a constant what color
was I using four constants 4/3 pi also a
constant so therefore in terms of what
they've asked us to do we would just say
V is K there's the cluster cubes
make sense so okay so um if you if you
didn't know the formula you just write
that yeah I'm actually writing the
formula just to illustrate for you like
what is the purpose of K well it's it's
how much does it get bigger by and we
actually know what it is in a lot of
contexts okay all right well the last
one there is C and this one is actually
very similar to the one I started with a
Kiehl's funny example Part C
yeah that's a great example what are the
two letters one of two things D and L
but it's not just any L it's the square
root of L so it's like this and then
there's the proportion symbol like that
so what's the equation this is actually
exactly Rene what you were talking about
before I don't know what the number is
at the front a fifth eighty whatever so
all I do is I just put in okay it is all
okay so and I should point out I should
point out this actually like not knowing
what K is is usually our starting point
that's usually where we begin and then
we find out like we record some data we
do an experiment we find out a certain
value of D that matches with a certain
value else I'll just give an example
what would you like do you know was
thankful just make something up
it has to be something to contain j--
I'm gonna call it length length of how
about the diameter how about the
diameter of your UC longness how about
the diameter of your arm versus the
length of your arm okay I'm just making
something else okay so then we may
actually measure okay what it was the
diameter of your arm looks like I don't
know maybe like not the diameter of my
arm well both can we go for like let's
just say like four centimeters can we
just make up a number diameter is 4 oh
yeah up here like it's at my wrist
okay anyway I don't know what K is okay
what would you estimate the length of
your um let's just get your forearm
what's the link it's about 30
centimeters right so I'm just looking
just okay all right we'll go with we'll
go with the diameter of my arm and
beyond and the length of yours that
would give us some great data guys okay
so let's go with 20 all right now in
this case having taken these two
measurements now I can work out what K
is equal to right um what would I do to
solve for K have a look have a look at
them on if one just solve for K I want K
on its own
I can hold on a second if I squared I
would get rid of this square root but do
I need like the square root applies just
to the 20 it doesn't apply to the K
that's why it comes after not before so
all in it yeah I just need to divide by
this thing get it out of the way right
so I'm gonna go up here K is going to be
4 divided by this square root of 20 okay
um do you guys have calculators there
can you give me one decimal point
[Music]
wicked you know it's like yeah I got to
play with this forbidden toy one order I
could give me two eight nine okay all
right so now what I did was I'll
actually highlight these right the first
thing I did was I created the variation
equation
I created the variation equation and
then secondly I put some values into it
usually that will come from the question
what is the question get it from well it
measured something right and it found
out oh this is a pair of values that
goes together the third thing is I then
used that measurement measurements to
find out what K is equal to and the last
thing is I can now update my original
equation I have an idea of what K is so
I will say that D is 0.89 times the
square root of L so now I have a proper
variation equation this one is like a
variation equation with some question
marks in it I don't know what K is but
you use the information at your disposal
like what whatever the question provides
to find out what it is okay